mewtwo braixen and Guerra chump join the  roster of pokin tournament the Pokemon  fighting game developed by tekken studio  bandai namco the reveal comes before the  official announcement scheduled for  january fifteenth thanks to a leak from  corocoro comic a japanese manga magazine  details are scant about the new  characters gara chomp is labeled as a  power category pokemon whose special  attacks include san tomb and dragon rush  braixen is a ranged fighter and will use  its Fire Blast as a special ability and  there's no word yet on Mewtwo's  abilities however pokin tournament  features not just one but two Mewtwo's  the pokemon company last November  unveiled shadow Mewtwo a boss character  in the arcade version of the game poken  tournament comes out on Wii U in spring  2016 wonder your thoughts on the new  characters and who do you think will be  the next announced characters voice your  thoughts in the comments below